as it stands right now this is a
two-minute time zone area time's up
chest cube meltdown time control 2
minute warzone rated 84 players
17:06 average rating time handicapped
time will be adjusted according to
player's ratings here we go all right
let's get off to a good start
give me my little timer get that out of
the way Oh double the points alright
let's go with this play play what I
really have to win every game to win
this tournament
don't you let's see start off solid
maybe get a little crazy later on b6
Bishop b7 hmm actually well I'm gonna
take here after the bishop moves okay
it's not doing that and go with this I'm
giving up my Center and if Bishop here I
think h6 and something like night to be
for later on
I have c5 in mind I might as well do c5
right now and I think h6 is gonna be the
right thing or maybe even g6 is in
response to this move not quite sure
this is still a bit too weakening
weakening those dark squares I'm I don't
know that bothers me so I'm not gonna do
that capture and then maybe capture
again rook here what's going on with
this I have my Bishop defended was that
missed Queen takes is a blunder is there
an in-between move I can make with my
knight I'm not seeing it minute 24 okay
let's go Knight and let's go rook I want
to target this let's double up I guess
or maybe Queen here I should play Queen
ease so much for that
get my night to see for I'm looking to
double up now that night could be
posting in the center looking to capture
and then target this guy okay I'm in a
position to get this guy right here I
have a flight square in this endgame
with still on minor pieces on the board
which is probably a very good thing see
takes wouldn't be played what it let's
do this I have a flight square c3 coming
under heavy fire back rank mates as well
I could trade Queens and then slip on c3
there's no time to take the a7 pun Oh
what's going on with that was that a
mouse slip I have a flight square was
that just missed must have been I'm just
up a clean for a rook now no resignation
the resignation let's just trade I don't
want those works to get excited about
these pawns over here thrown a check and
get a past a or veep on pick up the rook
somehow there it is the rook is picked
up come on this is a resigned time back
to tournament three two to clean sack is
up there okay double those points and
let's go with make up make up your mind
here here we go
Bishop d3 Queen e2 now I'm gonna take
the time to get this in I was just ready
to push again and do this okay this I'm
gonna throw another pot into the mix
what is my opponent doing these are
White's too many pawn moves what's going
on why they're making so many pawn moves
am I gonna get beat up
maybe I'm gonna go for a gambit target
f7 I don't want to have a pun on the F
file let's get this light squared bishop
out of here okay I probably should just
grab that pond what am i doing
Cal grab it now f7 grab this Knight push
this pawn I get at night b5 in I want to
keep this pressure this diagonal
pressure here what's the time I don't
have any time a minute six I might do
another sack just to open up the C file
go here Brooke c1 okay actually over
here since it's closed this Bishop shut
out of the game so now I'm close to
doing what controlling the light squares
for sure no I don't want to do that I
don't want to open up the H file get out
of there Bishop cannot deal with you
this is a little scary a little scary I
want to play h4
the bishop is close to trapped actually
it is trapped let's do this and and and
and get my king up just a little bit
let's back up here back up here and I
need to do some my Bishop needs to come
back that Bishop that rook needs to get
out of there I can't deal with that let
me take this and then I think I have
everything covered no not really
um oh this is sad oh this is real sad is
that a good move it is a good move
luckily I have this resource where my
rook could take and then I could block
Wow dodged a bullet there
dodged a big bullet check just trade
queens I want to trade Queens can you
have that happen yes it's happening so
now my King needs to play
let's go King I just dropped a pond uh I
got a pond back though okay this is
still winning I have enough time 19
seconds is a lot of time like a pre move
a lot here pre move 0.1 second moves not
like that though let's go push push push
push push one more he's guarded and then
I'll get this guy going just watch out
for steal me o clock burner is this a
clock burner they're not hitting the
resign button mm-hmm 23 22 21 it better
be the case that it's my opponent's
clock that's ticking come on let's go
here let's go 10 seconds somebody only
has 9 people have 9 points already back
to tournament I got 6 9 9 6 6 6 6 a
bunch of sixes okay deep Houdini uh-oh
tight game why'd I go with the old
Benoni Blumenfeld uh-oh let's try this
know what check and then night here and
then actually what what gets done next
why am I playing a gambit why not
Bishop a six maybe Knight takes pawn is
the threat Bishop a six we're about even
with time now so I have that back I have
that on my side we're both up there
early in the tournament with six points
each they're going into a think tank
they're think tanking it Oh actually you
know why because if Bishop here I just
take the knight and I'm on this ah I
didn't even see that initially let's try
this deflection and then deploy my dark
square Bishop here and what next this is
actually a pretty scary scary time okay
hit this on that Bishop and boy Bishop
e6 okay I have an idea or maybe I don't
okay let's go actually still okay I
guess this guy's going down he's toast
Knight d3 is the idea here I'm gonna
capture like this otherwise there could
be eventual Queen moves here something
ooh this is scary
come over here King is everything gonna
be okay my first thought was King here I
have these squares covered from the
Queen I just want to get my knight right
here Queen here is a losing move are
they gonna do it they're gonna do it the
Queen is cooked lateral movement oh
that's a killer isn't it it's a killer
I'm on the road I'm on the night they're
gonna play on I'm on the pond trouble
rook activity
there's no defense here I'm up on time
too right lateral movement by the Queen
what am i doing
actually I just want to take that night
kill the night and then kill this pawn
actually this pawn I want because then
the Knights homeless he's got to find a
new home now that night everything's
finally pushed upon resigned time get my
rep doing something resigned back to
tournament 2017 twelve twelve who has 25
games in for Queen sack for games fie
games who's this captain captain LJ all
right let's go Bishop Bishop c4 let's go
are they gonna take my bishop I get the
a file okay that was my a bad bishop by
the way f4 Knight f3 Castle target f7 Oh
light square weaknesses I was thinking
about Queen h5 there for a second
I'm gonna take my knight and help out my
development I'm gonna put pressure on
the night I could develop with tempo I'm
gaining more time Bishop e3 now should
be three something needs to be done here
we go open up the center I have a lead
in development get this pawn involved I
guess still get it involved I want to
get to d5 and why not this pawn it's
getting a little crazy baby but um I
think it's alright let's get my knight
in the center that's got to be
uncomfortable and maybe even my each pot
I want to get that involved they got a
giant pawn wall here and um okay let's
close this and now g5 next g5 next is
the plan
stop that my knight is really really
good I should have taken the night while
had the chance right maybe not oh I'm
taking this the eye of the Queen killer
fork the whole family's dead
the whole family went down right there
the Knight has to run home
a check if they take I get the rook the
rook is dead
this rook is dead to check and then me
and to actually then I asked a block
right don't tell me they're not gonna
resign they resign back to term in
twenty seven twenty twenty Queen sac has
a seven-point lead seventeen minutes and
change left
Roberto chess all right what are we
gonna have here Oh a small pond center
what is this Bishop doing okay I'm gonna
go with this the bishop is close to
being dead okay I have a giant space
advantage and I'm winning a pond now I'm
hitting the Queen I'm on this pond this
is guarded backup yeah because I want to
get this pond going what's that queen
doing no where's this night gonna go
what is that bishop doing I don't
understand the moves that White's making
here I'm gonna get a more pawns involved
maybe Queen here is gonna be played okay
let's stop that pawn push that Knights
gonna have to go somewhere else
get out of there Knight and let's go I
think there might have been some sac
right there I want to get my bishop on
e6 okay connected pass pawn here shut
down this Bishop if I have a pond here
this bishops dead gee files opening up
oh they missed that I'm on that they
missed that I'm on that more pieces
night on f4 I don't have four hit the
Queen hit the bishop Forks [ __ ] about
to Age 3 that's me back to chairman 30
got a lead three point lead five games
in six games were in for Queen sack
I guess they maybe slipped up with a
draw or a loss though so I have a little
bit of a lead 15 minutes and change and
let's go with this line here and it
didn't turn out so great the last
played this let's see if we could do a
little better Queen d2 Bishop e2 Castle
if my Knights might if my knight gets
chased away maybe d1 f - we're gonna see
about this maybe even a pawn push I
should have done a pawn push maybe I'm
gonna voluntarily go back so decision
time
I'm also in a position to watch over
efore I want to play c3 okay
there we go and I still think c3 is a
good idea okay now I'm supporting this
and what's my lights got a bishop doing
can you get doing some more stuff this
is a very forcing continuation on
wedding material Bishop takes I take him
on the Queen and the knight Knight here
I just take I'm still on the Queen I
just want a piece might be resigned time
resigned time I'm just getting the Queen
okay my knight wants to get to d4 let's
go
knight on d4 my rooks on f1 and II one
push and I'll recapture with my rook so
there's no discovered trick so actually
I think I'll just push no I won't I'll
consider it next maybe just double okay
let's come back here so I'm in a spot to
still double rooks in some way and let's
get this flight square and maybe get my
pawn to h6 okay that's a weakness can i
really take advantage of it I'm close to
doing that night here pawn push ideas
actually Knight here this is uh this
seems like it'll do the trick this seems
more appealing though for if there's a
capture hits everything and a knight
move here okay that rook is dead now if
King here it's a mating - the King has
to go here to avoid main two's
so I'll king here I take with check in
the event then they have 30 seconds I'm
on the bishop everything is hit 13
minutes and change when we have pin pin
and then win no good solution if the
bishop doesn't move it's taken if it
does move the rook is lost back to term
at 42:37 a little bit of a lead 13
minutes and change okay let's go with
this Knight f6 and what could have an
Enzo Indian I'm still gonna do this
right here
so Queen East 7 capture recapture we
could have a I was ready to just play
this move let's not do d6 until this
tension is resolved now I'm gonna take
and then get in these moves here get in
e5 my bishop is unprotected okay looking
for this square maybe here we go if 83
it's premature okay they needed a baby
step it now my Knights gonna have a
wonderful home on c5 and I think white
is in a difficult position so I take and
it's Castle and they're looking to maybe
double up soon okay actually that's a
bit of a pain isn't it
ah what do I want to do what's a good
idea here let's try this get rid of that
night in post I'm gonna capture this is
an incidence right think capturing away
from the Senators good Queen here
actually drops this pond I want to get
to d6 with my night and put pressure on
these guys and maybe play Bishop a6 rook
a4 as well I think first and foremost
this make sure that there's no thoughts
of this pond coming down although the
Queen is gonna play there right now hmm
my knight really wants to be here I need
to switch roles here f6 and then somehow
get my knight back to this d6 square
that's exactly what wants to be but how
does it get there I think I just ruined
my actually has to take a hike or does
it oh man I'm in trouble okay let's come
here it's gonna get hit anyhow and okay
what do I do what's the time situation
prepare to run it's getting scary over
here it's getting very scary and have a
bunch of trades or are we I guess Queen
hear that bishop could play here that
I'm in trouble if you didn't realize I'm
in trouble right here big trouble
what's my bishop I don't even know what
that move is doing don't don't even look
at it
Bishop to c8 what is that even doing ah
okay I got a trade a bunch and then how
to recapture I'm gonna go with this I
guess oh this is this is a killer Bishop
is gonna kill me I gotta do this
I think Bishop - okay maybe there's a
save or is there no
um I gotta go back I got a play here
next counter-attacking move to well I
don't have 12 seconds I'm dead
ah don't have any time right I'm
dropping that pond there's nothing good
here
can I win this can I win this I can't
win it where's my time where did my time
go I just want to get this night can I
get it
whoa wait a second just um four seconds
how much time I don't have anything I
don't want to try this what are we gonna
have here
three point three
two point four two point four I can't
talk
1.7 seconds I got a primo of everything
the game is drama of repetition oh thank
goodness it's a draw
oh man I was holding my breath I think
like longer than David Blaine right
there
you have no idea oh man I couldn't talk
I was tongue-tied right there oh man I
pulled a David Blaine I think I was
David Blaine in it okay you could
regroup you can do this don't you dare
give up okay let's go 95 Bishop d3 kill
that king come on don't you dare give up
don't you dare let giving up set in here
ah dark square week this is let's go
kill the bishop my queens getting kicked
away all right what do you do get rid of
that Bishop rook up and overs let's go
let's do this I can't I can't be too too
reckless or can I let's go H pawn and h5
h6 okay I have dark squares dark squares
dark squares h5 h6 made on g7 pawn push
I target this guy next I'm looking to
target this guy for right now Bishop 2f
low and Bishop 2 H 3 H 1 and then here
right here he's pinpointed and I want to
play over here too it's fun on the a
file fun on the a just defense I could
win a bunch of material could I I'm
winning material I'm on the Queen I have
flight squares doubled pawns but I'm on
these guys pac-man mode on the sixth
rank I thought the King might play there
ok this is good it's nice to actually
have some seconds in this game seconds
are good 1.7 seconds is not good
oh my rook is trapped are you kidding me
oh no it's not trapped is it it's a
trapped rook ah man you could still do
it can you oh this is brutal
I need to get rid of those ponds or
something oh this is so bad I want to
cry I just got I just hung my rug I just
hung my rug can I still get a try out of
this this is ugly
oh this is ugly oh man oh no they're
just gonna be a pine push or something
oh this is bad I just dropped I ran out
of squares the guy ran out of squares is
my opponent nervous hopefully they're
nervous I got nothing
can this still work it's not working
it's not working
Oh hit the resign button or not wait why
didn't they play King here I'm still
beat though I'm still be go here yes
it's actually it's not working
it's still win it's still a win and I
might as really at the resigned button
oh I want to cry I want to go on a
corner and cry oh five minutes and
change I'm not even gonna get confetti
now after that one oh can you believe
that the King snuck over my rook was
short on squares ah ah man there's only
one thing that can save me
I gotta go fishing right now this is it
I gotta go fishing against quick finger
I need seven fishing poles in a row
seven of them it's not gonna happen
f6o wait for it wait for it the other
fishing poles now happen in these longer
ones oh man or does it h2 don't come
yell 54 I'm after that confetti
I got a burst I got a burst right there
come on come on come on come on come on
man let's go maybe if I click it faster
a little pair me up
let's go 72-69 67-65 pair me up you have
to play to win here we go
putz 12 double the points and resign yes
that's what I'm talking about
72 70 it's like they heard me
Oh back in the mix even though after a
draw and a brutal rook trap another
reside back to tournament who's in first
man one of my parents and paying these
people a for what okay I'm showering
them with cubits look at this a
miraculous comeback I'm pulling a
Houdini earlier was a David Blaine now
it's Udine ee5 more fishing pole I'm in
a mask it Castle you know you want a
castle uh-huh yeah hi fishing ball get
out of there night
okay now let's not drop a rug come on
three minutes and change come on you
could do it you could do it you could do
it get the bishop's off that's the first
order of business dark skirt Bishop's
off the board second order of business
drop a knight on d6
and the game is over isn't it or is it
okay my opponent says no there will not
be dark square bishop exchange and
that's understandable let's take this
guy though I could be giving a check but
I don't want to do that maybe I should
have okay I'm gonna go here now this
Knight needs to get out of here he's a
giant pain of pond takes I have to take
with my bishop
that's a concession actually no no no
take it take my bishop that's okay
take him just take him he's free I want
my queen to get here and then made on h7
two minutes 50 seconds let's go
that Knight needs to get out of there
you gotta go night get it out of there
what do i do what do i do what's this
cleanup - Oh what is she up to what is
she up to over here don't you dare get
over here on e - what's the clock
situation actually I'm just gonna be
able to get in this one game right here
there's not gonna be another game after
this they're being sneaky
quit being sneaky the bishop was ready
to play at e3 ah stop that I don't want
to play a three because there's crazy
sacrifices and stuff so I want to let my
ponce it my queen us to watch over this
guy now okay I can see a little bit
clearer now finally oh I'm dropping C -
I got Forks though watch out for those
forks forks forks forks here and then
land a fork now bishops gonna come back
or is it Fork what's the what's the
count a minute 40 a minute 40 okay take
care
please let everything be okay just trade
a little bit I'm really I'm really
paranoid about every Brooke move every
rook move I I make I'm just thinking
that I'm dropping it oh man Oh Oh check
check scary check where's the mate come
on you gotta give me hang out let me
take a pun can I do that safely
one minute six give me the Queen's now I
can move faster finally but hang on hang
onto that rook look at this still set me
up for disaster I got to watch for the
sneaky pawn move my king needs to play
push the pawn push that pond here run
pawn I'm gonna kill the bishop and then
get a queen
42 seconds okay I got this check give me
this guy with check this game is gonna
have to finish
I'm not gonna burn up too much time
where am I
go here kidding it's me don't you dare
gets stalemate
next up where is it that's not it yeah
twelve seconds when we got what do we
got oh what can you do can I at least
get second don't let somebody else can I
have a quick resigner quick resigner
quick resigner oh it's not deafening
come on Queen and Bishop you could do it
you could do it you could do it you
could do it right here right here right
here right here oh it's so close I was
trying to get deaf to ah second place
I'm lucky to even get second with that
Oh crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy
110 99 I was lucky to get that confetti
I was lucky to be up there quick
resigner has helped me along the way
otherwise I would have no chance I'm
getting top three